Dann herzlich willkommen zur Alternativlos, die Folge nummero 12.
Diesmal mit zwei Gästen. Wir haben nämlich das Neusprech-Blog eingeladen. In Persona Professor Martin Haase und Kai Biermann.
Schönen guten Abend.
Ja, wir wollen heute reden über Neusprech, also die Art und Weise, wie unsere Sprache sich immer mehr verhunzt, um auch so ein schönes Wort zu benutzen.
Nein, sie wird kreativer.
Sie wird kreativer.
Das ist ein Zeichen von Kreativität und von der Lebendigkeit der Sprache, dass damit so viele Leute so viel Unfug anstellen.
Dinge auszudrücken, die man gar nicht gesagt hat, ist doch großartig.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich bin froh, dass wir Gäste einladen, dass es nicht immer so negativ ist.
Genau, dass es nicht immer so negativ rüberkommt. Auf jeden Fall. Ja, vielleicht machen wir mal ganz kurz mit unseren Hausmeisterthemen.
Ja, wie üblich, vielen Dank fürs Flattern. Das ging ja weiter. Noch während wir die letzte Sendung aufgenommen haben, nach der Pause, kamen schon die ersten Flatters wieder rein. Vielen Dank dafür. Das absurdistanen Revolutionsspektakel ist eigentlich so überwiegend gut angekommen. Zwei, drei Leute waren nicht vollständig erfreut darüber, aber...
Aber dabei waren wir noch gar nicht fertig.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich noch die Opposition spalten.
Was sich ja eigentlich gehört für so einen guten Diktator. Und ich hätte dann, glaube ich, noch irgendwann zu Assassination Politics aufgerufen, also einfach...
Wir sind relativ zivil geblieben, das war schon okay.
Ja, aber vielleicht machen wir davon noch mal eine Fortsetzung, wenn wer gelegen hat, dazu haben. Ägypten hält ja noch eine Weile an. Ja, auch in Ägypten kann man diesen kreativen Umgang mit der Sprache...
Ah ja, das ist doch konzentrierte Beispiele....
an so einigen Ecken beobachten. Also...
Ja, mein Informationsminister.
Ah.
Das wünsche ich mir ja eigentlich auch bei uns.
Ja, das braucht man. Das ist schon richtig.
Und der jetzige Vizepräsident, der ehemalige Geheimdienstchef, muss man sich so ungefähr so vorstellen, jetzt die Situation wie, als wäre so im Herbst 89 Erich Mielke irgendwie zum Beauftragten für die runden Tische anhand worden.
Oh ja.
Also, um es zu transponieren. Der hatte da ein paar sehr schöne Sätze gesagt, so als die sich im Wesentlichen um... Wir sind doch alle Ägypter und wir wollen doch alle Stabilität haben. Und wenn wir unseren geliebten Präsidenten nicht mehr haben, dann haben wir auch keine Stabilität mehr.
Ja, das wundert mich sowieso, wie man das sagen kann, dass der geliebte Präsident für Stabilität sorgt, denn der ist dann auch schon nicht mehr so ganz jung und nicht mehr so richtig stabil.
Na ja, aber 30 Jahre im Amt, da träumt doch die Merkel von.
Aber nochmal 30 Jahre.
Dann hat sich Marcole das geschafft.
Also, sehr gut, also 30 Jahre wird er wohl nicht mehr durchhalten. Also steht nicht, zumindest nicht zu vermuten. Na gut, also was ist denn das Neusprechblock und warum macht ihr das und wie kommt ihr dazu?
Fangen wir an.
Du bist der Professor.
Na gut, also dann, wenn ich anfange.
Na, was ist denn die Idee?
Ja, gut, mag sein. Also nicht ganz. Also du hast angefangen mit dem Schäuble.
Du hast angefangen, irgendwelche Vorträge zu halten.
Keine Schuld zu weisen.
Das Ganze ging natürlich wie immer im Chaos Computer Club los.
Tatsächlich, ja.
Und zwar ging es damit los, dass der C3D2, das ist der Chaos Computer Club Dresden, von mir einen Vortrag haben wollte. Und zwar über Neusprech. Und da hab ich gedacht, das ist ja gar nicht mein Thema. Dann hab ich das lange vor mir hergeschoben, das sollte erst auf irgendwelchen Datenspuren stattfinden. Da hab ich gedacht, ich muss mich erst mal einarbeiten. Ja, und dann hab ich mich irgendwann halbwegs eingearbeitet und hab da einen Vortrag gehalten. Und dann hab ich gedacht, hm, eigentlich könnte man doch den Vortrag auch mal auf dem Kongress halten.
Also vielleicht solltest du noch erwähnen, dass du von Hauptberuf Linguist bist.
Richtig, genau. Ja, also ich beschäftige mich mit Sprachen, allerdings nicht unbedingt mit dem Deutschen. Deshalb war das für mich schon was Neues. Und ja, ich hab's dann halt auch gemacht. Also die dachten halt, die Dresdener, ja, so ein Linguist, der soll mal was über Neusprech sagen.
Und so, ne? Also, ist doch irgendwie so.
Und ich saß im Saal, als er diesen Vortrag hielt.
Der ist auch echt gut angekommen beim Kongress, der da schon lief.
Und ich saß da rum und dachte, da könnte man was draus machen.
Genau, und dann ging's eben gleich weiter mit diesem kleinen Innenminister, Neu-Schwerter-Buch von Kai Biermann. In Bei-Beit-Zeit online. Ja, und das ist auch gut angenommen worden. Und dann haben wir uns gedacht, wir tun mal unsere Kräfte zusammen.
Nein, da ist erst mal drei Jahre lang nichts passiert.
Genau, ja.
Das ist doch schon mal eine gute Vorbereitung.
Ja, ich hab jetzt so ein Wurmloch da. Naja, jedenfalls irgendwann nach drei Jahren haben wir uns dann zusammengefunden.
Per SMS.
Genau, ja.
Und das neu-sprechblog behandelt ja immer einen Begriff in einem Blogpost meistens. Richtig. Um mal zu erklären, wo der herkommt und wie der so entstanden ist. Und wie er unsere Sprache bereichert oder verunsiert.
Naja, wir sind ja auch vor allen Dingen immer so auf der Suche nach dem, was der eigentlich wirklich aussagt oder was er versteckt. Also sollte schon, also wir haben ja auch das Motto bei uns, dass Sprache es an den Tag bringt. Das ist ein Zitat von Victor Klemberer, auf den wir sich ja auch noch zu sprechen kommen werden. Und ja, also wir versuchen dann auch tatsächlich so ein bisschen ja Sprachaufklärung zu betreiben. Und das kann man auch den einzelnen Artikeln ganz gut ansehen.
Das Wort Neussprech kommt ja aus dem Roman 1984 von Orwell. Aber so dieses Phänomen ist doch bestimmt auch schon ein bisschen älter, oder?
Das Phänomen ist älter. Also Orwell selbst hat ja schon einen Artikel vorher, also lange bevor er das in dem Roman geschrieben hat, über die englische Sprache bei Politikern geschrieben.
Und welche Zeit war das?
Ja, das ist auch so in den vierziger Jahren gewesen.
Also schon so Kriegszeit, Kriegsrhetorik.
Kriegsrhetorik und auch dann auch die Nachkriegsrhetorik, wo es ja dann in England auch noch weiter ging. Die hatten ja große Probleme, soziale Probleme. Und da hat er eben die Sprache, also die englische Sprache etwas näher untersucht.
Aus Enttäuschung über das Phänomen, glaube ich.
Ja, kann sein. Auf jeden Fall hat er auch noch älterer, auch bei seinem Roman 1984, hat er noch auf ältere Sachen zurückgegriffen, als zum Beispiel auf den Roman May, also Wir von Samyatin.
Stamm Samyatin.
Und da ist es natürlich auch, in dem Roman geht es natürlich auch sehr stark um Sprache und vor allen Dingen, wie der Titel schon sagt, um dieses Wir-Gefühl, was da aufgebaut wird. Der Roman ist auch sprachlich sehr interessant, weil der Autor auch versucht, in der Sprache so ein bisschen diese rationale Gesellschaft, die es da gibt, abzubilden. Deshalb ist das auch vielleicht nicht ganz so schwer auf Russisch zu lesen, wenn man noch nicht so viel Russisch kann, weil es zum Teil auch versucht, so ein bisschen so eine rationale Sprache nachzuahmen, obwohl es dann doch wieder mit den ganzen Fachbegriffen, also ich hab's versucht und bin dann doch sehr in Schwitzen gekommen, weil ich ständig im Wörterbuch nachgucken musste. Aber jedenfalls ist das ein Roman, wo es eben auch um die Sprache dieser rationalen Gesellschaft geht. Und den kannte Orwell, denn er hat eine Rezension zu dem Roman geschrieben, und zwar kurz nachdem der erschienen ist, also noch in der Vorkriegszeit. Und das ist natürlich klar, dass er dann darauf auch zurückgegriffen hat, auf diese Ideen.
Wenn du gerade sagst Sprache der rationalen Gesellschaft, dann müsste ja eigentlich China geradezu ein Füllhorn an interessanten Sachen sein. Stimmt. Also die harmonische Gesellschaft scheint ja das große Ziel zu sein, was am Bestrebe wird und der...
Ja, wenn ich Chinesisch könnte, könnte man das da sicherlich sehr gut, könnte ich das da sicherlich auch sehr gut untersuchen.
Wobei die Kultur dann noch viel weiter geht in China, weil sie mit ganz anderen sprachlichen Bildern arbeitet als wir. Also mit dem, was wir so untersuchen oder was wir so aufschreiben, geht es ja eher darum, dass irgendein Beamter sich versucht hat, einen Begriff auszudenken, um etwas zu beschreiben, was in seinem Alltag leider vorkommt, wie das Internet. In China geht es ja viel eher darum, ein fast literarisches Bild zu finden für irgendein gesellschaftliches Phänomen. Also die Tatsache, eine Filtersoftware grüner Damm zu nennen, in dem Gedanken, dass man das Netz schöner machen will und bunter und wie eine Wiese vor sich sieht, ist ja geradezu großartig. Also ich meine, solche Lyrik würde ich einem deutschen Beamten nie zutrauen.
Ja, das mit der Blümchenwiese war aber auch in Deutschland schon mal unterwegs.
Das kam von mir.
Ach so.
Es ist keine Blümchenwiese mehr, es ist tatsächlich von mir.
Na also, da sieht man alle Seitenarbeiten mit der Sprache.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, es ist verunscht.
Da kommen wir auch noch.
Na ja, man muss ja immer mit dem Kreis machen, das ist Kreativität.
Genau.
Sprache ist ein Instrument der Macht für jeden.
Das ist Ausdruck oder so ähnlich. Also eines der Worte, die uns natürlich beschäftigt ist, der Titel unseres Podcasts, nämlich Alternativlos, der ja zum Unwort des Jahres 2010, also es hat das Wort geworden.
Wir waren zuerst da.
Ja, allerdings.
Es gab sogar eine Deutschlandradio-Sendung, an der ich teilgenommen habe, über das Wort Alternativlos. Kann man sicherlich auch noch irgendwie finden bei Deutschlandradio.
Irgendwie drei Tage nach Gründung des Blogs. Ich fange jetzt überrascht.
Das ist nicht der erste Sportzimmer oder fast?
Fast. Nee, nicht ganz, aber am Anfang.
Ja, relativ am Anfang. Und da gab es auch einen sehr schönen Einspieler, der leider nicht in die Podcastversion gekommen ist, beim Deutschlandradio. Das ist immer so, das ist immer diese Geschichte mit dem Depublizieren und Rechte und sonst was. Es gab einen Einspieler von Anja Mauro Schott, wo sie lauter Zitate von Merkel hintereinander gemacht hat, wo sie immer was von Alternativlos sagt. Und das ist dann immer abgespielt worden. Also es gab ein solches Zitat, dann ein Kommentar und dann wurde wieder Alternativlos eingespielt in anderem Tonfall von Merkel. Das war großartig, aber leider ist das irgendwie depublikiert worden.
Ja, lustigerweise genau dieses Wort Alternativlos war ja auch der Grund, warum wir jetzt hier zusammensitzen, weil ihr beim Kongress meintet, dass unsere Verlinkung des Wortes bei euch im Blog, also wir haben ja von Alternativlos einen Link rüber zum Neusprech-Blog.
Danke dafür.
Dass da relativ viel Treffel kommt.
Jeden Tag 10 bis 15 Klicks.
Das ist in der Statistik der eigentliche Einstiegsport.
Also die einzigen Klicks, die wir überhaupt kriegen, streng genommen.
Na gut, das wird vielleicht ein bisschen mehr nach der Sendung.
Wir sollten vielleicht noch mal extra ansagen, ganz analog neusprech.org heißt das Blog.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall. Viel Spaß. Den dir das Abonnement wert. Ja, dann wollen wir vielleicht mal ein bisschen anfangen mit dem, wofür verwendet man dieses Neusprechend denn eigentlich? Also wir haben ja schon so ein paar Beispiele genannt zwischendurch. Alternativlos ist sicherlich eins davon, was immer so ein bisschen so rüberkommt, wie so eine Verweigerungshaltung. Also so das Implizieren eines gesellschaftlichen Konsenses oder eines politischen Konsenses, der vielleicht eigentlich überhaupt noch nicht da ist, aber der, also man ist dann ja der Abweichler, wenn man sich dagegen stellt und etwas nicht alternativlos verwendet.
Also alternativlos ist eben, es geht nur so. Das wird halt dann irgendwo absurd. Und wenn halt die Bundeskanzlerin, und das war ja dann auch der Anlass, und diese Zitate sind dann eben auch in diese Sendung von Deutschlandradio eingegangen, wenn sie dann plötzlich von alternativlosen Beschlüssen oder alternativlosen Entscheidungen spricht, denn ich meine, wo ist die Entscheidung? Wenn es alternativlos ist, dann hat man gar nichts entschieden. Das ist halt irgendwie dann das Sonderbare bei der Sache.
Wie kommt denn das, dass man es heute per Wortschöpfung macht? Und früher hat man ja noch simuliert, dass man Entscheidungsfindung hat.
Nein, nein, nein. Die Sprache ist tatsächlich ein Instrument, der Macht und wer die Sprache diktieren kann. Diktiert die Geschichtsschreibung, diktiert die Wahrnehmung, diktiert die gesamte gesellschaftliche Umgebung.
Ist das nicht glaubwürdiger, wenn ich als Politiker so tue, als hätte ich die Optionen evaluiert und die anderen sind alle schlecht, als wenn ich sage, es gibt gar keine? Also ich meine, für mich ist die Frage, ist das einfacher, funktioniert das besser, wenn ich da Neusprech benutze, als wenn ich tatsächlich einen Prozess simuliere? Also wenn ich politische Prozesse vor Augen habe, ich war mal bei so einer Anhörung zum Thema Hacker-Tools im Bundestag und es ist mir halt damals offenbar geworden, dass es alles nur Theater war. Die haben das veranstaltet, damit keiner aus formalen Gründen das Prozedere kippen kann.
Aber es wirkt.
Nichts davon ist benutzt worden. Da habe ich mich gefragt, naja, das ist doch eigentlich eine gute Methode. Wenn ich Diktator wäre, das würde ich doch genauso machen. Warum machen die Leute denn jetzt so was wie Neusprecher und machen das nicht weiter so?
Na ja, das andere funktioniert auch mit Neusprech. Also das ist dann immer, es ist ergebnisoffen, diskutiert worden und so. Also das ist dann die andere Argumentation. Und das kennen wir ja alle. Ich meine, ein wirklich für mich traumatisches Erlebnis war die Einladung der SPD vor dem Zensursula-Gesetz, wo sie das Internet eingeladen haben.
Und du warst das Internet?
Ich war einer davon.
Du warst ein Internet?
Ich bin von dem Internet. Also das war wirklich ganz lustig. Und dann hieß es eben, ja, es sollte keine Pressemitteilungen geben über die Falschschreiber. Wir wollten mal so richtig off-record da diskutieren. Also keine Pressemitteilung. Dann hat die SPD aber selbst eine herausgelegt. Ja, natürlich. Und hat dann geschrieben, ja, es fand ein Treffen mit der Internet-Community statt. Da ist schon so ein Wort, die Internet-Community. Und man habe die Bedenken der Internet-Community ernst genommen.
Und ausräumen können oder auswärmen.
In Lammern. Es wurde aber nichts verändert an dem Gesetz.
Natürlich nicht.
Aber man wurde ernst genommen. Also ich meine, das ist natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit, mit der Sache umzugehen.
Aber das kennt man doch aus dem US-Fernsehen, oder? Wenn sie sagen, wenn du so eine Holtlein anrufst und sie sagen, lieber Anrufer, wir nehmen ihr Problem sehr ernst. Aber jetzt kommen sie erst mal für zehn Stunden in die Warteschleife. Ich meine, alle, die so anfangen, wir nehmen sie sehr ernst, ist doch das Gegenteil, oder schon von sich aus?
In dem Augenblick, wo dir so eine Holtlein sagt, unser Problem ist uns wichtig, ihr Problem ist uns wichtig, dann weißt du genau, dass du eigentlich genau wie auflegen kannst.
Ja, das ist schon viel gelernt.
Ja, aber das ist eben der Punkt. Also es gibt da zwei Strategien. Die eine ist, die Dinge ernst zu nehmen und dann aber in der Entscheidung alternativlos zu sein. Das ist halt, das passt zusammen. Auf der einen Seite gibt es halt keine Alternative und auf der anderen Seite wird aber auch die Alternative ernst genommen.
Und es funktioniert trotzdem, das ist das Schöne. Es gab mal einen römischen Senator, der soll jede seiner Reden beendet haben mit den Worten und im Übrigen bin ich der Meinung, dass Carthago vernichtet werden muss. Was ist so?
Nee, Cato. Ach, Cato, der Ältere.
Glücklicherweise. Haben wir einen Professor da, genau.
Der Kai weiß immer alles, wie das Professoren so tun.
Es hat funktioniert, Carthago wurde vernichtet.
Na ja, na gut, das war nochmal eine andere Strategie, dass man halt immer wieder die Dinge ins Gedächtnis ruft.
Man muss die Dinge immer nur wieder so formulieren, wie man sie gern hätte und dann wäre sie Realität.
Aber Alternativlos ist ja eigentlich genau das Gegenteil davon. Alternativlos ist doch eigentlich der Versuch, ein längeres Nachdenken über das Problem abzublocken und zu sagen, wir haben da schon lange drüber nachgedacht und jetzt können wir mal aufhören, darüber zu reden, weil wir sind jetzt durch mit der Diskussion.
Ja, ob ich nur sage, ich sehe, also ich finde, Katago muss vernichtet werden und das mit Nachstruktur. Oder wenn ich sage, diese Entscheidung ist alternativlos, dann musst du sozusagen, wir müssen das alle tun. Das ist doch letztlich sind es nur zwei Wege, um ein Ziel zu erreichen, mit Sprache so einzusetzen, dass ich als Einzelner das Gefühl habe, ich muss da nichts mehr entscheiden.
Denn nicht drüber nachdenken.
Na, es ist eigentlich relativ geschickt, weil es den Sprung von ich sehe keine Alternativen zu, es gibt keine Alternativenschaft, ohne ihnen explizit zu sagen. Das ist eigentlich schon ein relativ beeindruckender Sache.
Das ist bei Politiker-Rhetorik ja schon immer genau dieser Spagat zwischen, wir haben uns das Problem genau angeguckt und jetzt müssen wir aber mal handeln. Also jetzt müssen wir mal Führungsstärke beweisen oder...
Geschlossenheit.
Geschlossenheit, was ich dann immer besonders schön finde, so aus dem...
Ihr solltet mitbloggen...
.aus dem Osten kommt. Geschlossenheit ist natürlich auch immer so die Einheit von Partei und...
Die Einheitsfront.
Die Einheitsfront war ja dann noch sozusagen die nächste Verschärfung davon.
Die Nazis haben nur die Reihen geschlossen, die Sozialisten haben dann die Einheitsfront draus gemacht.
Ja.
Ja, wie war das mit den jüdischen Volksfronten?
Das war in dieser Tiefe. Übrigens, also Lebensbrein gab es ja im Osten auch nicht, ne?
Was? War verboten?
Fand nicht statt.
Existierte nicht.
War einfach nicht da. Ach.
Das war religionskritisch.
Das hätte man doch...
Naja, nicht nur religionskritisch. Also wenn die Staatsreligion halt zwar nicht religiös ist, aber dann doch irgendwie alle da Züge einer Staatsreligion aufweist, dann ist ja doch...
Das ist ja hart.
Nee, das war auch einer der Filme, die mir nach der Wende so am meisten Erkenntnis gewinnt hat.
So funktioniert das Beste.
Aus der Rubrik. So funktioniert das Beste.
Stimmt. Da musste man ja dann auch was lernen nach dem Zusammenbruch der DDR.
Vor allen Dingen neue Sprache.
Neue Sprache fand ich interessant. Ich hab ja 1991, ziemlich viel, 92 auch ziemlich viel Zeit verbracht in einem Publizistikarchiv der FU, wo man noch so die bis 45, 46 zurück, so Spiegel und Quick, die damals auch eine richtige Zeitung war und so was. Oh, warte, das muss ja mal lange hier sein. So eine Handausleihe hat so.
Das ist ja unglaublich.
Ja, so richtig. Die gibt's ja so richtig als jahresgebundene Bände. Und dann kann man so die Pausen zwischen den Seminaren, sich da hinsetzen und da lesen, sehr entspannt. Und dann hab ich mir halt so ein bisschen die westdeutsche Geschichte anguckt. Und mit der Sprache fühl ich mir auch sofort auf, dass die halt so eine ganz andere, merkwürdige Sprache haben, aber die auch wieder so eine, so über die Jahrzehnte so eine gewisse Ritualisierung erfahren hat. Also so ein gewisses, dass die alle dann immer so dieselben rhetorischen Tricks benutzt haben oder immer so dieselben Vokabeln und so alles. Und wie sich das dann so entwickelt hat, ist ja sehr interessant, mal so alte Zeitungen zu lesen. Der Spiegel hat zum Glück sein Archiv weitgehend online.
Das war das Sturmgeschütz, oder?
Nein, das war der Spiegel, das ehemalige Nachrichtenmagazin. Wo wir mittlerweile zu ehemaligem Sturmgeschütz übergegangen sind.
Ich warte noch ein bisschen. Na ja, eigentlich ist ja ein ehemaliges Meinungsmagazin. Jedenfalls, das geht natürlich in beide Richtungen. Also wir im Westen haben ja begeistert den Schwarzen Kanal geguckt.
Ernsthaft?
Natürlich. Und da hast du auch gesehen, dass die so eine ganz eigene Rhetorik hatten. Oder gelegentlich gab es ja bei uns auch mal so Ostzeitungen. Also jetzt nicht am Kiosk, aber man durfte ja als Westberliner schon in den Osten fahren, wenn man sich da ein bisschen vorbereitet hat. Und bei der Gelegenheit haben wir natürlich Zeitungen geguckt. Und das ist schon so eine ganz andere Sprache. Das merkt man sofort. Aber man kann so nicht den Finger drauf tun, was jetzt konkret anders ist. Aber es ist also natürlich gibt es so ein paar Kampfbegriffe. Natürlich der anti-imperialistische Schutzwahl und solche Dinge. Aber auch wie Politik beschrieben wird und wie der Gegenüber beschrieben wird.
Ne, antifaschistische Schutzwahl.
Entschuldigung.
Genau. Entschuldigung.
Nein, aber ich meine, das führt ja...
Klassenfeind.
Genau, der Klassenfeind. Aber ich meine, das geht ja noch weiter, als es in der DDR gegangen ist. In Nordkorea sprechen sie ja den Namen der USA schon gar nicht mehr aus. Dann haben die nur noch...
Wolken? Warten sie das oder irgendwie? Nein.
Aber da ist es nur noch... Oder ich meine, es ist auch die Araber gegen Israel. Da heißt es auf der einen Seite nur immer die Zionisten.
Ach so was gibt es im Internet auch.
Das gibt es überall, natürlich, klar.
Bei motortalk.de zum Beispiel, diesem Autoschrauber-Forum.
Motortalk.
Ja, da sagt man nicht den Namen einer Werkstatt oder Werkstatt überhaupt, sondern sagt, ich war beim Freundlichen. Warum auch immer. Das ist auch so eine Form von Selbstzensur.
Ist das vielleicht so eine Gruppenbildung, dass man dazu gehört, wenn man das auch so macht?
Naja, oder zumindest der Versuch irgendwie, sich nicht allzu sehr als Werbeträger im Netz zu etablieren. Das ist durchaus auch ein Ding. Was ich auch noch sehr schön finde in diesen Diskussionen, jetzt gerade um die S21 in der Schicht in Stuttgart, war ja dieser Begriff Fortschrittsverweigerer. Also diese Implikation, dass wenn man jetzt an diesem Projekt nicht mitmacht, dass man dann prinzipiell gegen jeglichen Fortschritt der Menschheit und überhaupt an Technologie in der gleichen Dinge......
mit dem man eigentlich die Bundesrepublik unterscheiden kann.
Ja, das ist ja klar. Also sozusagen die Stuttgart 21 sei Fortschritt wird unterstellt.
Ja klar, das ist halt so die... Also die prinzipielle Annahme ist, wir geben da viel Geld aus und dann fahren da schicke Züge durch. Also muss es sich dabei ganz eindeutig um Fortschritt handeln und wer da nicht mitmacht, ist halt ein Fortschrittsverweigerer. Und insbesondere aus dem Munde von Politikern, die ja nun mit Technologie berufsbedingt nicht so richtig irgendwie, also die sind ja technologiegehandicapt in der Regel. Zumindest was das Verständnis angeht.
Also drucken können sie.
Naja, ich hab ja immer so den Verdacht, dass nachdem wir aufgehört haben, diese Vokabel Internetausdrucker zu benutzen, haben die wieder angefangen auszudrucken.
Ja und einzuscannen dann anschließend.
Und als Attachment an eine Mail zu hängen?
Naja, ja genau. Nein, also wir hatten das ja, dass es so Diskussionen gab, dass man die Unterlagen der BVV irgendwie auch besser zugänglich machen wollte. Und dann stellten wir fest, dass es immer Schriftstücke gab, die waren, das war zwar ein PDF, aber das war eine Grafik. Ja. Obwohl die das ja in den BVV-Biros erstellt haben, also BVV ist die Bezirksverordnetenversammlung in Berlin, also die kommunale Ebene. Ja und was man daraus, also ich habe dann daraus geschlossen, dass die das zwar im Büro erstellen, dann aber auf dem schönen Briefpapier ausdrucken, um es dann wieder einzuscannen. Und das ist natürlich tatsächlich ausdrucken und einscannen.
Deren Prozesse sind halt papiergebunden. Früher hat man eine Kopie gemacht und heute kann der Kopierer eben auch das Scannen als Mail rausschicken. Insofern, alte Prozesse sterben langsam.
Na ja, wir kommen ab vom Thema.
Na ja, der Internetausdrucker ist auch ein schönes Neusprechendlich. Absolut.
Ja, es war halt der Versuch eben genau da mal ein bisschen zu kontern. Also das haben wir ja mit den Wahlcomputern angefangen. Wo es ja darum ging, genau diesen, also was ja so die Gegenseite hat sich immer als Wahlmaschinen bezeichnet, also als ein Gerät, das nichts anderes tun kann, außer diese spezifische Funktion wahrnehmen. Also es wird suggeriert, dass es sich um einen mechanischen Mechanismus handelt. Da greifen halt Zahnräder ineinander. Da kann man halt nichts weiter tun. Das ist halt eine Maschine.
Und eine Maschine funktioniert auch meistens in einer bestimmten Weise und ist nicht modifizierbar so leicht.
Kannst du keine neue Software entspielen jedenfalls?
Ja, also genau. Dieses Special-Purpose-Maschine war ja der Begriff, den sie da immer gerne verwendet haben. Wohingegen wir den Begriff des Computers gesetzt haben, zu sagen, was technisch sogar korrekt ist, also zu sagen, es handelt sich eben um einen Wahlcomputer, also um eine elektronische Vorrichtung, die programmierbar ist und ihr ein Stück Software ausführen kann, mit dem man eben dementsprechend umprogrammieren kann. Und der Internet-Ausdrucker war dann halt so der nächste, also die nächste Steigerungsform sozusagen in diesem Kontext, halt einfach mal auch einen Kampfbegriff zu setzen gegen diese Generation, die versucht, da über etwas zu entscheiden, wovon sie schlicht keine Ahnung hat.
Schon wieder der Kampfbegriff.
Ja, klar, natürlich.
Die Funktionen von Neussprech kämpfen.
Ja, natürlich, klar, in diesem Fall.
Na auch vernebeln. Also wir haben so eine Liste mal gemacht, die versuchen wir jetzt gleich mal alleine auch durchzugehen.
Na ja, wir sind ja gerade schon dabei. Also der, der, ihm diese, dieses Schlachtfeld der öffentlichen Meinungsbildung ist ja. Schlachtfeld. Ja, jetzt kommen auch die Kriegsmetalle hier.
Belizismen.
Die, die funktionieren ja immer in mehrere Richtungen. Interessant von hier, dass der als Diskussion um diese, was die Bild dann Nacktscanner genannt hat, also weil es tatsächlich nur Vokabel die Bild rein gebracht hat.
Und damit hat es ihn erledigt.
Ja, und damit, genau, also zumindest.
Eine Zeit lang.
Dachten wir es bisher, also mal gucken, wie es weitergeht. Also mittlerweile erledigt sich diese Technologie offensichtlich von selber wegen akuten Versagen.
Na ja, aber es ist lange gestoppt worden, wegen der Begrifflichkeit. Und die ist auch nie so richtig weggegangen. Also ich meine, eigentlich hat ja de Mesier da die goldene Neusprechnadel verdient, weil er ja im Parlament gesagt hat, mit mir wird es keine Nacktscanner geben, mit mir wird es Körperscanner geben.
Ach, das hat er so gesagt?
Das hat er so gesagt im Parlament, ja. Kann man raussuchen.
Ach, da kommt ja diese Körperscannerbegrifflichkeit her.
Ja, die kommt vom Innenministerium.
Also sie ist eine Übersetzung des amerikanischen Buddyscanner. Das Innenministerium.
Was denn so ein bisschen harmloser klingen sollte.
Neutraler.
Wobei bei Körperscanner fiel immer als erstes so Körperfresser.
Ja, genau, ich denke auch, das reicht ja nicht.
Er hat halt nicht weit genug gedacht, weil der Körperscanner immer noch zu körperlich ist.
Jaja, klar.
Und man muss irgendwie auf was anderes kommen. Also der richtige Begriff, um das zu verkaufen, wäre so was wie Sicherheitsscanner oder Passagierscanner.
Seelenscanner.
Flugscanner oder irgendwie sowas, wo man halt wirklich vernebelt, was es eigentlich ist.
Nun, gib ihnen mal keine Tipps hier. Also lustigerweise kommt es ja gelegentlich vor, dass ein Begriff so verbrannt wird, dass sie einen Gegenbegriff brauchen. Und das ist mir dieses Jahr, nein, letztes Jahr erst klar geworden, dass Kernenergie sowas ist. Kernenergie ist der Gegenbegriff der Energiemafia, weil Atomenergie verbrannt ist als Begriff. Und dann brauchen sie was anderes. Und deswegen heißt es jetzt bei denen immer Kernenergie.
Und sogar Kernkraft, was noch schöner ist. Kernkraft ist noch schöner, ja. Kann man auch wirklich sehen an den Plakaten, wenn die mal, wenn wir in Berlin gab es da mal vor einiger Zeit so eine Kampagne pro Kernkraft, da stand doch immer nur Kernkraft drauf. Und irgendwie Atomenergie.
Ich hab das immer total, ich meine, ich hab ja diese ganze Sache eigentlich miterlebt, aber mir ist das immer total wertgleich, wertneutral.
Das Schöne an der Kampagne war, dass das da um CO2 ging und nicht um Kernkraft.
Ja, also das ist schon lustig. Ich mein, das war ein echtes Aha-Erlebnis für mich, als ich gesehen hab, dass der ganze Begriff eigentlich eine Lüge ist. Nur vernebeln soll.
Also diese Vermeidung von negativ assoziierten Begriffen ist ja die Technik dahinter, also zu versuchen, die Diskussion dadurch umzubauen, dass es halt irgendwie nicht jeder gleich zusammenzuckt, wenn er irgendwie das Wort hört und denkt so, nicht schon wieder das oder so. Und also Atomkraft war halt nach Tschernobyl halt durch. Und jetzt mit Kernkraft haben sie halt dann natürlich die Debatte auch so gleich wieder. Genau. Weil das de facto ist, ist ja diese Worte sind dann eben auch so was wie Uniformen. Um ab und zu bei Kriegsrhetorik werden. Aber du identifizierst dich sofort. Das war bei den Wahlcomputern auch so.
Bei welcher Gruppe du mit bist, die die Worte benutzt haben.
Präzise. Wir hatten beim Verfassungsgericht, bei der Anhörung war uns klar, dass wir mindestens zu 50 Prozent gewonnen haben, nachdem die Hälfte der Richter Wahlcomputer gesagt hat. Und dann halt nur in der Urteilsbegründung irgendwo noch mal Wahlmaschine vorkam. Aber im Wesentlichen haben die tatsächlich Wahlcomputer als Begrifflichkeit übernommen. Damit war schon klar, dass sie den Inhalt dessen verstanden haben, worum es da ging. Und eben nicht den Begriff des Herstellers übernommen haben. Und bei Kernenergie versus Atomkraft ist es ja genau dasselbe. Weil wenn du Kernenergie sagst in einer Diskussion oder schreibst, ist sofort, bevor du auch nur deinen Satz zu Ende gebracht hast, ist vollkommen klar, auf welcher Seite der Barrikade du stehst. Und das ist, denke ich mal, auch ein interessanter Aspekt dieser Neuwortbildung, dass man sich praktisch schon durch die Wortverwendung mit der einen oder anderen Seite assoziiert.
Ja, bei der Online-Überwachung ist ja ähnlich. Online-Überwachung oder Bundesteuer. Wobei ich ja der Meinung bin, Computerwanze wäre noch schöner als Bundesteuer.
Die Vier und Zweite ist danach später ein, also ja, ist halt, naja, ist halt auch mal ein bisschen schwierig mit der Kreativität, die kommt dann auch nicht über, was sie sein soll.
Aber wir arbeiten dran.
Aber diese, diese, diese...
Ja, das ist aber auch eigentlich nicht selbstlaufend. Ja, also finde ich zumindest, das ist eigentlich erst, wenn du dich mit der Debatte beschäftigt hast, dass dir das auffällt, dass es verschiedene Worte für das Gleiche gibt und dass die von verschiedenen Lagern kommen. Also da wollen wir hin. Das ist eigentlich hervorragend, dass wir so weit sind, dass wir das erkennen können, schon an den Worten.
Ja, manchmal funktioniert es ja nicht selbstverständlich leider. Also bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt es ja nur dieses eine Wort, also Data Retention, was eigentlich viel schöner ist, weil das negativer klingt, also da hat man kein Pendant im Deutschen. Also bleibt man bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung und das ist schon irgendwo ein Problem. Auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich das Wort Vorratsdatenspeicherung inzwischen auch so entwertet worden, dass auch die Politiker nicht mehr damit zurechtkommen. Und so, das ist ja meine These, sagt dann Peter Schaar jetzt zu seinem neuen Projekt Quick Freeze, obwohl Quick Freeze eigentlich was anderes ist.
Also diese, naja, ich meine, Quick Freeze ist ja auch so ein, der Versuch eben negativen Begriff zu vermeiden. Also Quick und Freeze klingt erstmal harmlos so. Schnell ist vorbei. Kurz in den Kühlschrank machen, ist schnell vorbei, ist kühl, angenehm, so. Und es wäre das selbstverständlich, die Assoziation, um die es halt geht so. Und der, genau diese Begrifflichkeit wird auch immer gern verwendet, wenn es um diese Reformdiskussion geht. Also so Reformkommunikation ist ja das schöne Wort für, wenn sie mal wieder erklären müssen.
Reformkommunikation ist Neusprech für Neusprech.
Neusprech für Neusprech. Ja, stimmt.
Überhaupt dieses ganze Reformwort ist völlig verbreitet in den letzten Jahren.
Reform hat eine völlig neue Bedeutung als noch vor vielleicht 20 oder 30 Jahren.
Seit die Initiative Neu-Soziale-Marktwirtschaft.
Und seit die Sozialdemokraten halt auf dem Turnier Blättrip sind.
Na, aber die haben es doch übernommen. Das kommt doch von dem Interessenverband der, wie heißt das, Metallindustrie, die Arbeitgeber, womit wir schon beim nächsten Neusprech sind. Der Arbeitgeber-Lobbyistenverband, der hat sich eben unter dem Interessenverband Neu-Soziale-Marktwirtschaft zusammengetan, was so eine Art Initiative heißt das noch?
Initiative Neu-Soziale-Marktwirtschaft.
Initiative klingt auch sehr positiv, ganz super. Und das ist eigentlich so ein Lobbyladen, die eben versuchen, ihre Agenda unter das Volk zu bringen. Und dazu gehört unter anderem, wir können wieder Vollbeschäftigung haben und wir brauchen nur mehr Reformen. Und die haben ganz tolle Neusprechwörter gebaut. Also Reformstau finde ich eines der großartigsten Neusprechwörter, die es überhaupt gibt.
Dazu brauchten sie aber erst mal Reform als Begriff, ne? Also dazu brauchten sie erst mal die Besetzung des Begriffs Reform als grundlegende Änderung des sozialen Vertrages.
Na überhaupt, Reform kannte ich vorher nur von Reformhaus. So gesundes Essen, oder? Das war vorher die Assoziation. Also das Wort gab es zwar auch so im politischen Kontext, aber...
Ich bin Ossi, da gab es keine Reform.
Da gab es keine Reform, also?
Also Reform war 1990 eigentlich noch halbwegs positiv besetzt.
Staatsgefährdend.
Ja, naja eben positiv besetzt. Also Reform war irgendwie eher was, was wir so wollten, so, ja. Das war irgendwie schon... Und das hat dann im Westen, im Westen halt eine ganz andere Bedeutung gewonnen, so in den 90ern, war schon irgendwie eine erstaunliche Beobachtung. Und den...
Aber ich glaube, das war im Westen auch schon älter. Da gab es schon Bildungsreform und so.
Und ja, eine Reform ist eigentlich immer das Kampfwort gewesen. Wenn du nicht sagen wolltest, in welche Richtung es eigentlich geht. Ja, wenn du eigentlich sagen willst, wir ändern jetzt was. Nö, nö, politisch gesehen jetzt. Also wenn du sagen willst, wir ändern was, aber du willst dich nicht festlegen, ob es wirklich besser wird für die Wähler.
Dann sagst du, wir machen jetzt eine Reform.
Natürlich wird es schlechter. Aber das sagst du halt nicht dazu, sondern sagst Reform, weil das schön wertneutral ist eigentlich. Und der Wähler hofft dann, es wird alles besser. Genau, Steuerreform.
Es gibt seit Jahrzehnten eine Steuerreform, nach der nächsten habe ich noch nie einen Vorteil von Kaffee.
Und das ist immer so der Nebelkerzenbegriff, was ja auch eine wichtige Funktion von Neussprech ist.
Und es fing mit der Reformation an. Die gleichen Kirchen, nur ohne Entlastung. Gibt keine Beichte mehr. Oder auch schlechter.
Sie hatten auch keine Ablasshandel mehr, oder? War das nicht auch eine?
Keine Chance mehr, dich zu erleichtern. Das ist doch furchtbar.
Aber das war doch der Kern des Bösen eigentlich bei der Kirche.
Das war doch der Clou der Kirche, der erst mal sozusagen da hingehen konnte und ging hinterher befreit davon. Und alles war gut. Plötzlich haben sie alles genommen.
Von deinem Geld befreit vor allem.
Ja, mein Gott, was ist schon Geld?
Danach gab es dann halt Schuldkomplexe und ökonomischen Nachwuchs.
Und kein Gold mehr an den Kirchenwänden.
Ja, zeugt's.
Die Sache mit den Reformen ist natürlich, also hatte ich gerade vorhin schon erwähnt, eben genau Setscher und Blair waren ja in Großbritannien auch ganz weit vorne bei der Umbenennung von allem Möglichen. Und die haben ja angefangen, das sehr systematisch zu betreiben. Also die haben ja richtige Regierungsagenturen für Umbenennung von allem geschaffen, wo sie Behörden umbenannt haben. Die hießen dann plötzlich Partnership for oder Association for something oder hatten dann so, dann fingen sie halt an, diese, wie sie nichts sagen, sind Logos. Also diesen Schwurbel oder so wie gerade das Google Logos, gerade momentan ja auch so eins aus dieser Serie von so bunten Flecken, die so nebeneinander, abstrakt nebeneinander gehängt sind. Und dann steht da drunter irgendwie sowas wie ein Kunstname, mit dem man nichts mehr anfangen kann.
New Labour, finde ich das schönste. Der gleiche Kram heißt halt neu.
Ja, die Abgrenzung.
Wie mit dem neuen Personalausweis, das ist ja auch so eine Sache.
Na, das ist aber ganz was Neues.
Der ist viel neuer, meinst du? Ist gut, weil es neu ist. Das ist so ein ganz altes Verfahren.
Du Fortschrittsverweigere.
Genau, ich Fortschrittsverweigere.
Na, aber ich glaube neu ist auch so ein Wort. Also mir ist das ja aufgefallen, da mit den in Frankreich, mit den Unterstützern von Sarkozy, der nun mit Sicherheit ein eher rechter Politiker ist. Und diese Gruppierer nennt sich Nouveau-Sozialist. Also die Neu-Sozialisten. Und Neusprech ist ja auch so. Also die Neu-Sozialisten sind halt keine Sozialisten. Und naja, also... Und dann gibt es ja noch eine Steigerung davon. Man denke an die neuartigen Empfangsgeräte. Nichts empfangen eigentlich.
Ich musste erst mal...
Neuartig?
Suchen, was sie meinten. Ich dachte, sie reden von irgendwie...
Fernsehern.
Digitalradio war so meine erste Assoziation.
Jaja, genau.
Ich dachte so, sie reden von jetzt kommt jetzt digital Audio Broadcasting dann doch oder so, als sie von neuartigen Empfangsgeräten.
Wobei neuartiger noch cooler ist als neu.
Jaja.
Neu reicht nicht mehr. Da musst du was Neues her.
Naja, ist ja dann so die Klasse des Neuen so neuartig, ja?
Das ist ein Paradigma.
Ein Paradigme.
Wir kennen das ja alles. Frank und ich sind ja total abgehärtet, weil wir kennen das ja alles aus dem Dotcom-Bubble-Booster. Da gab es ja nur so Paradigmen, Wechseler und es ist bei uns alles neu und anders und da haben wir auch genug Bullshit-Bingo gehört.
Disruptive Change.
Ja, genau. Schmerzlos nach.
Ja, stimmt. Die Dotcom-Bubble hat auf jeden Fall eine Menge dazu beigetragen, solchen Begriffen irgendwie eher mit einem grinsenden Auge gegenüberzustellen.
Na, es gibt ja einen ganzen Industriezweig, der davon lebt, Berater sprecht, zu verkaufen.
Obwohl das ja mittlerweile schon so ist, dass die, also da sich so eine gewisse Allergie aufgebaut hat. Also diese...
Nur weil es jetzt eine Facebook-Gruppe dazu gibt, meinst du?
Nee, auch so bei Leuten, die das sich den ganzen Tag anhören müssen. Also die dann von diesen Beratern halt die Präsentation gehalten bekommen.
Das ging los mit Bullshit-Bingo, ne? Also die Idee ist, dass du so einen 5x5-Raster hast mit häufigen Bullshit-Begriffen wie Paradigmenwechsel, ja? Und dann setzt du dich in so eine Präsentation und kreuzt immer den durch, der gerade kommt. Und wer als erster eine Reihe oder eine Spalte voll hat, ruft halt Bingo. Und das ist Bullshit-Bingo. Und das ist schon im Jahre 2000 sehr populär gewesen unter diesen ganzen. Unser Produkt ist so neuartig, da gibt es noch gar keinen Namen für die Kategorie. So, ja, bla.
Aber natürlich werden die auch anehmend besser, ne? Also ich meine, es gibt ja jetzt, wie wir gesehen haben, eine Professur für Reformkommunikation.
Die ist inzwischen umbenannt, wie heißt sie jetzt? Für politische Kommunikation.
War innen doch zu offensichtlich, ja. Na, wobei. War das nicht der Lehrstuhl, wo sie irgendwie, dass die Journalisten abgeschafft haben?
Das war Leipzig.
Das war Leipzig, ja. Ja, das war Leipzig, wo sie den Journalisten-Lehrstuhl abgeschafft haben und dafür einen für Bullshit-Bingo eingerichtet haben.
Genau. Also da wird das auch betrügen. Also man sieht, die arbeiten dran. Und dann ist natürlich tatsächlich, sind diese Think-Tanks, wir hatten ja Bertelsmann schon erwähnt, die arbeiten natürlich auch an solche.
Think-Tanks ist auch schön.
Ja.
Alleine der Begriffe?
Ja, ist auch Neusprechplan. Naja, aber wir haben es ja gesehen bei den Studienbeiträgen, da habe ich auch die Dokumente ausgraben können, die sind auch verlinkt im Neusprech-Blog, wo tatsächlich eben versucht wird, das Wort Studiengebühren in einem Text immer durch Beiträge zu ersetzen. Also zu einem Zeitpunkt, als niemand Studienbeiträge gesagt hat, dann haben sie immer geschrieben, Studiengebühren schrägstrich Beiträge und inzwischen ist das der offizielle Terminus. Das haben dann irgendwie die Entscheidungsträger überall gemerkt.
Die Entscheidungsträger.
Ja, wir nennen es Studienbeiträge.
Wir sind so negativ bei dem Gerede hier. Wir dürfen was nicht vergessen. Das hat eine Funktion. Diese Sprache ist ein Heilsversprechen. So funktionieren Religionen seit Jahrtausenden. Es verspricht mir, ich bekomme etwas für mein Geld und ich werde mich nicht belogen, sondern ich werde mich verbessern. Es wird schöner und es wird neuer. Und ich werde eben nicht beschissen. Ich werde es dann doch wie immer, aber es verspricht mir etwas. Und ich glaube, das ist diese Faszination. Die darfst du nicht vergessen dabei. Warum verwenden die Leute es sonst?
Also du meinst, die Leute hören sich so was an, weil sie glauben...
Sie wollen glauben, dass es besser wird.
Wollen auch alle ein Neuen.
Ich möchte doch, dass eine Steuerreform tatsächlich zu einer Steuerentlastung führt. Bei mir auch, nicht nur bei irgendweren, der sich das ausgedacht hat.
Bei FDP-Mitgliedern.
Entlasten durch Steuern, das ist großartig.
Also du meinst, dass eine der wesentlichen Funktionen von neusprechliches Aufrechterhalten ist Optimismus.
Der Lebensfreude.
Den Leuten was geben, an dem sie sich hochziehen können.
Hoffnung.
Das Obama-Prinzip. Naja, aber was der Effekt der mittlerweile ja eintritt, ist doch aber eigentlich eher ein anderer. Nämlich dadurch, dass mittlerweile alle politischen Ideen, selbst die, die irgendwie noch ehrlich und gut sind, oder mal gewesen sind, mittlerweile so zu Tode gespindoktort sind und eben genau mit diesen Begrifflichkeiten zugekleistert sind. Wir hatten ja in der letzten Vorletzten Sendung schon mal erwähnt, es gibt ja mittlerweile eigentlich keine Möglichkeit mehr für einen Politiker noch ehrlich zu sein.
Glaubt ihm eh keiner.
Nee, selbst wenn jetzt da einer, nehmen wir mal an Obama hat es ehrlich gemeint, der war der Letzte, der noch die Chance hatte. Also er war sozusagen der Letzte, wo man noch irgendwie mal, zumindest mal viele Leute, die ich so kenne, die das Gefühl hatten, so okay, dem versuchen wir jetzt noch mal zu glauben. Dem versuchen wir jetzt noch mal irgendwie zu glauben, dass es nicht nur Phrasen sind und dass er irgendwie ehrlich meint und dass er wirklich eine Änderung will. So und irgendwie so change we can believe in. Was haben wir mittlerweile? Ich meine, change we can believe in ist mittlerweile unser Schlagwort für den ganzen Scheiß geworden, den er macht. Und das aber heißt es eben, dass es an den Punkten erreicht hat, wo genau diese Verwendung dieses Neusprech so überstrapaziert ist, dass zumindest bei den Leuten, die da noch drüber nachdenken, mittlerweile der Zynismus echt groß geworden ist.
Du redest jetzt von dir.
Nicht nur von mir, auch so von Leuten, die irgendwie im politischen Betrieb unterwegs sind oder die.
Es kommt das nächste schöne Wort, das wird auch dich begeistern.
Nämlich? Ich dachte du hättest es gerade.
Wir haben noch eins gehabt, freiheitsschonend.
Freiheitsschonend war wunderbar.
Ein tolles Wort.
Grundrechtsschonend, ja.
Erst kam ja Grundrechtsschonend und dann, also ich hab ja immer die Vermutung, dass die Leute unsere Texte lesen. Grundrechtsschonend, die ist irgendwie komisch.
Das können wir noch toppen.
Freiheitsschonend.
Das können wir noch toppen. So zwischen den Kokslinien, das toppen wir nochmal.
Freiheitlich wäre dann das nächste.
Aber die interessante Frage ist, wie würde denn ein Ausweg aussehen? Also gäbe es denn einen Ausweg? Also könnte denn?
Aus dem Leben?
Nee, aus der Verwendung von Sprache, die nur noch eine Zweckstimmung hat. Also gäbe es noch eine ehrliche Sprache?
Nein, natürlich gibt es keine ehrliche Sprache, weil Sprache ein Instrument ist und alle Seiten natürlich irgendetwas rüberbringen wollen.
Also ich frage mich halt deswegen, wir haben halt irgendwann bewusst angefangen, das Spiel mitzuspielen und solche Begriffe selber zu setzen. So und durch das ja auch Erfolge gehabt, kann man nicht anders sagen. So nur die Frage ist halt, ob wir damit nicht das Rad eben genau wieder ein Stück weiter drehen und am Ende nur dazu beitragen, dass es halt noch weniger Möglichkeiten an das Ausweg ist, gibt es also.
Der Ausweg ist wie bei den Gefahren des Straßenverkehrs, Bewusstsein schaffen.
Ja, naja.
Abschaffen kannst du das Risiko nicht.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob man nicht mal wie so in so einer amerikanischen Slapstick Komödie so den total überzeichneten Politiker losschickt, der einfach nur noch transparentes Bullshit-Bingo von sich gibt, um mal zu sehen, wie weit er kommt. Ja, das glaube ich nämlich auch.
Du kannst du doch gerade beobachten. Ich meine, der CSU Netzberichter oder der Bericht des Netzrats.
Dorothee Bär.
Ja, das ist doch nur, wenn man das liest, ist man doch völlig in den Kopf gestoßen. Da ist so viel Neusprech und nicht nur Neusprech, auch so komische Formulierungen, wie wir müssen irgendwie die Instrumente, das Recht.
Grundrechtsschonend.
Ja, dann.
Verfassungskonforme Umsetzung.
Genau, verfassungskonforme Umsetzung. Man kommt aus dem Kopfschütteln und facial bei mir überhaupt nicht mehr raus.
Aber es gibt ja so Begriffe, die dies dann irgendwie länger schaffen. Also so was wir vorhin schon hatten, so Arbeitgeber, Arbeitnehmer. Ist ja so brutalstes Neusprech eigentlich. Also früher hieß es irgendwie Arbeiter und Fabrikbesitzer. So war wenigstens noch klar, worum es geht. So und oder Ausbeuter, Kapitalisten, Kapitalist. Genauso war es so klare Begrifflichkeiten. So dann wurde daraus irgendwie im Zuge der sozialdemokratischen Reformen Arbeitgeber, Arbeitnehmer. Und die diese Begrifflichkeit ist mittlerweile so verankert, dass es eigentlich kaum noch eine andere gibt.
Man kann sich gar nicht mehr neutral über das Thema unterhalten.
Und da denke ich mal, ist so ein...
Ja, wobei ja gleichzeitig auch ein Bewusstsein wächst, wie länger so ein Begriff verwendet wird. Und wie du ja selber sagst, die kehren sich ja um. Irgendwann benutzen die Leute ihn ja genau entgegengesetzt.
Genau. Ja.
Das ist ein Prozess wie alles im Leben.
Wobei gesagt, diese Arbeitgeber, Arbeitnehmer ist ja nun schon seit den, keine Ahnung, wann es in den 60er-Jahren oder so kommt.
Seit er hat.
Seit er hat. Also jedenfalls schon so lange dabei, dass da...
Das kennt man gar nicht mehr anders. Alle Leute, die heute darüber diskutieren, kennen das gar nicht mehr anders.
Und es wird auch nicht zynisch verwendet so.
Nö.
Warte ab.
Wenn die Leistungsträger noch ein bisschen weitermachen.
Ja gut, die Leistungsträger. Ja, das stimmt. Leistungsträger ist natürlich schon hart an der Grenze. Die sind schon hart auf der Grenze zum Kippen. Aber diese Verwendung als Angriffstechnik, also sprachliche Angriffstechnik, ist ja gerade im Bereich der Sicherheitspolitik sehr üblich. Also da haben wir ja...
Pre-emptive strike, mein Lieblingswort.
Genau. Oder surgical strike oder so. Da gibt es ja auch die...
Da geht es ja auch wieder eigentlich um die Begriffsbesetzung. Da möchte ich den Begriff eigentlich so formulieren, dass überhaupt nicht die Frage aufkommt, ob das tatsächlich ein surgical strike ist.
Eine Unstärke demonstrieren von...
Oder preemptiv. Ja, ich meine...
Druckkulisse.
Ja, ich sage nur, Vorwärtsverteidigung war so unser unser Favorit bei der Ausarbeit.
Vorwärtsverteidigung war so ein Ding, wo es mir als erstes auffiel. Also das war so ein Begriff, ich dachte so, hä?
Ja, früher haben wir...
Was meinen Sie denn so?
Früher, also die Preußen, haben doch einen Kriegsminister gehabt. Kriegsminister, ja? Das ist heute nicht mehr vorstellbar. Heute haben wir ja nur Verteidigungsminister, die dann unsere Freiheit am Hindukusch verteidigen.
Die DDR war die einzige, die einen Abrüstungsminister hatten.
Und hat der was abgerüstet?
Ja, er hat ein paar Panzer verschrottet, bevor er selber abgerüstet wurde und ersetzt durch einen Verteidigungsminister.
Das ist auch viel wichtiger. Wurde am Ende sogar zum Verteidigungsminister umbenannt, ne? Der hieß doch nur kurze Zeit Abrüstungsminister.
Das ist ja ein böses Schicksal.
Ja, ja. Was ihn auch, glaube ich, hart getroffen hat, aber.
Das ist fast wie mit dem Nibel, ne? Der hat ja genauso, den hat er jetzt hier zum Entwicklungshilfebeauftragten gemacht und dabei wollte er zur Bundeswehr und hat argumentiert, dass der Posten weg muss.
Stimmt, sie haben genau den Posten gegeben, der weg sollte.
Das machst du eigentlich nur mit Leuten, die du echt gar nicht leiden kannst.
Die ganz persönliche Vorhülle hier.
Und wie ist deine Rechnung, du Arsch?
Aber in dieser Punkt, dass eben gerade so Kriegsrhetorik eingesetzt wird bei der inneren Sicherheit, da denke ich ja, dass das auch planmäßig geschieht. Ich meine, das ist seit langem ja ausgemachtes Ziel der konservativen Kräfte in diesem Land, dass man halt die Bundeswehr im Inneren einsetzt. Und da kann man ja wunderbar schon mal das Feld ebnen, indem man halt für die innere Sicherheit immer wieder, insbesondere für die Leute, die man irgendwie anschwerzen will bei der inneren Sicherheit, indem man eben da die gleichen Wörter nimmt, wie für Leute, die im Krieg irgendwie auf der anderen Seite stehen.
Anschwerzen ist eigentlich auch nicht schlecht.
Ja.
Verraten meintest du?
Ja, also es ist ja offensichtlich so, dass es hier eben darum geht, bestimmte Leute schlecht zu machen oder irgendwie zu Terroristen oder zu Kommandanten, Aggressoren und sonst wie hoch zu gestalten.
Stören, gefährden. Ja.
Also wie die anderen Meinungen sind.
Wobei ja ein Teil dieser Vokabeln ja durchaus eben aus dem Militärsprachgebrauch rübergeschwappt ist. Eben aus der Berichterstattung über die Kriege in Afghanistan und Irak.
Das kommt doch aus der Doktrin richtig.
Aus dieser Alltagsgewöhnung an diese militärischen Begrifflichkeiten eingesetzt hat. Genau wie die Leute angefangen haben, plötzlich irgendwie Flecktarnhosen zu tragen oder halt irgendwie die Mode militärischer wurde. Genauso hat sich eben auch der Sprachgebrauch militarisiert. Also das ist einfach so diese Alltagsbegrifflichkeiten, die eigentlich hier kein Alltag waren, sondern eben nur über die Berichterstattung hierher kamen, dass die immer mehr in den normalen Sprachgebrauch eingingen. Also das ist ja durchaus auch so ein Effekt von Krieg, der schon mehrfach irgendwie festzustellen war. Also wenn Kriege waren, dass sich dann eben auch die Sprache änderte. Und eben ja die, die mal die Frontbegriffe dann auch in die Zivilgesellschaft eingesickert sind. Und gerade halt im Bereich der inneren Sicherheit ist natürlich besonders intensiv zu beobachten, wie denn halt einfach die auch die Abgrenzung so, wir versus die. So also die da sind die Störer, Gefährder, Kombattanten so und wir sind irgendwie die zu sichern den Bürger.
Aber eigentlich sollte man doch von einem Innenminister, der ja auch Verfassungsminister ist, erwarten, dass er da sehr vorsichtig ist und eben solch ein Vokabular nicht verwendet. Wenn er das also tut.
Schäuble wollte auf jeden Fall nicht vorsichtig sein.
Ja, genau. Wenn er das so tut, hat er eine Absicht. Das ist nicht einfach nur so, weil alles militärisch ist. Wird ja auch militärisch, sondern er hat eine Agenda.
Ja, klar. Aber ich glaube, dass die Gewöhnung an die militärische Begrifflichkeit kam eben auch über die allgemeine Berichterstattung. Wenn halt einfach die Nachrichten zur Hälfte aus Berichten von der Front in der einen oder anderen Form bestehen, dann sickert natürlich einfach diese, die Bundeswehr, die Bundeswehrsprache, also eigentlich mal über Bundeswehrsprache fast eine eigene Sendung machen. Die Bundeswehrsprache ist ja hochgradig merkwürdig. Also die haben ja so immer so riesige zusammengesetzte Wortketten, die sie dann zur Abkürzung zusammen schrumpfen. So interessanterweise, lustigerweise genauso wie bei den sowjetischen Begriffen.
Ja, Kompartei und komintern und so.
Ja, die auch immer so die Abkürzung aus den ersten Söbel zusammengesetzt haben. Und diese Militarisierung des Sprachgebraus zieht sich ja dann eben auch zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, bei Computersicherheit. Gibt's die? Naja, also als Feld, als Industrie. Es gibt eine Industrie. Es gibt eine Industrie dazu. Und auch da ist festzustellen, dass eben diese Militarisierung des Sprachgebraus sehr deutlich geworden ist, dass man halt immer noch von Angreifer redet, von Verteidigungslinien und dergleichen Dingen.
Das liegt auch an uns, dass wir immer von Angreifer reden. Also ich rede absichtlich von Angreifer und nicht von Hacker, weil ich gerne den Hackerbegriff so ein bisschen freihalten möchte.
Klar.
Wofür? Na, für gute Leute, die sich mit der Technik beschäftigen und nicht...
Umdeutung, ja.
Ja, nee, eigentlich der Hackerbegriff heißt... Ursprünglich heißt Hacker ist eigentlich jemand, der sich mit der Technik wirklich genau beschäftigt und wissen will, wie das alles funktioniert und ist nicht jemand, der woanders einbricht.
Umdeutung, weil es hatte lange eine andere Bedeutung.
Nee, die haben es umgedeutet und wir möchten gerne den alten beantworten.
Rückdeutung, Rückdeutung.
Rückdeutung ist auch ein schönes Wort. So wie Informationswiederbeschaffung.
Rückführung. Wie kommt denn, dass das Euphemismen früher aus Fremdwörtern zusammengesetzt waren, sowas wie Euthanasie oder Neoliberal und dass wir heute eigentlich nur noch...
Ist heute aber auch so. Es hat nur die Sprache gewechselt. Also Englisch ist jetzt immer ganz nett. Online ist modern. Online ist die Suchung. Oder da gibt es eine ganze Menge. Targeted Killing wurde gesagt. Das geht auf Englisch gar nicht. Aber es klingt halt deutlich besser als gezieltes Töten.
Rettungsschuss. Das war doch eigentlich... Wie war der...
War das nicht gezielt?
Finaler Rettungsschuss. Genau. Das war doch auch irgendwie so...
Ich glaube, das ist ein Moden. Eine Zeit lang war halt französisch modern und ländisch.
Ich hab da so ein Wort bei euch in der Liste gefunden. Den Warnschuss-Arrest. Den fand ich ja fast wissen. Was meinen Sie denn?
Das ist von Merkel.
Das ist von Merkel?
Der war von Merkel, ja.
Und was meinte sie?
Das war der Warnschuss, den der Jugendliche hören soll, bevor er tatsächlich niedergeschossen wird, das nächste Mal.
Ach so, ist es sozusagen ein...
Arrest, um vor dem Arrest zu warnen.
Also im Sinne von Schuss vor den Bug so als...
Genau. Wir schicken dich in den Knast, um dich davor zu warnen, dass du in den Knast kommst, wenn du das nächste Mal noch wieder so was tust.
Großartig.
Toll.
Sehr zierisch, ne?
Ja, aber auch militärisch.
Ja, der Warnschuss ist der, den ich abgebe, bevor ich gezielt auf denjenigen schieße, den Athleten.
Ist auch ein Schuss. Man kann ja auch sagen, Verwarnung. Ja, Verwarnungsarrest oder so.
Wobei Arrest ja schon schön ist, weil es ist Knast. Die kommen richtig in Bau.
Krass.
Na ja gut, aber unterbindungsgewasam.
Unterbindungsgewasam. Das ist auch echt.
Sagt auch nichts über Knast.
Wobei es ist was dran. Wir bewahren dich davor, dass du wirklich Blödsinn machen kannst. Wir müssen dich dazu leider einsperren, aber wir bewahren dich weiter.
Ja, es könnte auch sicherheitsgewasam sein.
Es ist ja noch schwer. Sicherheitsgewasam. Sicherungsgewasam.
Ja, das ist auch ein komisches Wort.
Das ist auch toll. Es geht doch um die Sicherung.
Sicherung. Das wird eigentlich gesichert.
Da gab es im MDA, glaube ich, gab es einen Bericht über jemanden, den sie halt in so einen Sicherungsgewasam genommen haben.
Ist das nicht Sicherungsverwahrung?
Nee, es ging um einen Hooligan, den sie, da gibt es da diese Sicherungsverwahrung. Diese sächsischen Regionaldinger, diese für 48 Stunden.
Das ist das Unterbindungsgewaschen.
Genau. Und dann hatten sie die Mutter von dem interviewt und die meinte nur so, ja sie haben ihn fortgeschafft. Das war irgendwie eine sehr präzise Beschreibung.
Da gibt es auch noch, früher wurde er abgeholt.
Ja, genau.
Na internieren ist ja auch so ein altes Wort sogar. Internieren, aber eben auch euphemistisch.
Na das ist aber auch sehr negativ belegt heute.
Ja, deshalb ist es ja verbrannt. Die Wörter kriegen dann doch wieder ihre Bedeutung zurück und da muss man sie durch was anderes ersetzen.
Wenn du heute von Internierungslagern redest, das ist gleich eine ganz üble.
Ganz üble, ja.
Da muss ich mich immer echt zurück zusammenweißen.
Ja, aber der Lager war ja auch ein Euphemismus.
Ja, natürlich.
Aber jetzt hat sich das Wort seine Bedeutung wiedergeholt.
Okay, also du meinst, die Worte holen sich irgendwann ihre Bedeutung wieder.
Das kannst du immer wieder sehen. Das siehst du hier bei dem Lager, bei Internieren, das siehst du aber auch bei so was wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung, was ja auch ein Euphemismus war. Und heute ist es wirklich zu negativ. Das kann schon keiner mehr benutzen. Stimmt. Und auch umgekehrt funktioniert das. Das wird ja auch bei Klemperer, jetzt hab ich ihn schon wieder erwähnt, beschrieben mit dem, was hatte er da, das Wort fanatisch. Das wurde von den Nazis so oft verwendet, dass es hinterher nicht mehr ausreichte. Und dann ist es gesagt, Göbbels in der Sportpalastrede, wild fanatisch. Weil fanatisch allein nicht mehr wild genug ist.
Wo wir gerade bei Klemperer sind, vielleicht sollten wir da kurz drüber reden.
Wir müssen ihn kurz erwähnen, den Mann. Der war großartig.
Ja, Victor Klemperer ist ein Sprachwissenschaftler für Romanische Sprachwissenschaftler. Also genau mein Fach an der Uni Dresden war der tätig. Also in der Zeit schon kurz vor dem Nationalsozialismus. Und dann gab, hatte, bekam er halt Schwierigkeiten, weil er irgendwie jüdische Vorfahren hatte. Und ist dann eben auch seines Amtes da enthoben worden an der Uni und hat dann die Sprache der Nationalsozialisten beobachtet und in seine Tagebücher halt Notizen vorgenommen und die dann auch auf Zetteln, also in so einem Zettelkasten sortiert. Und dann hat er kurz nach Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs seine Notizen von diesen Zettelkästen publiziert. Also über die Sprache des Nationalsozialismus. Und das Buch heißt LTI. Das war nämlich sein Geheimname für diesen Zettelkasten. Und heißt Linguo Aeterci Imperii, also Sprache des Dritten Reiches. Und ja, das ist halt kurz nach dem Krieg, ich glaube, 1946 schon veröffentlicht worden. Und da geht es halt eben um die Sprache des Nationalsozialismus. Und also sehr viele, also wirklich immer gesammelt, wenn er da Wörter gefunden hat, die ihm aufgefallen sind. Und eben diese Geschichte mit dem Wildfanatisch hat er da beobachtet. Oder auch andere formelhafte Ausdrücke, wie in stolzer Trauer, was immer in den Todesanzeigen stand. Und natürlich viele Einzelwörter und auch Wörter, die es auch zum Teil bis heute gibt. Also das Dachorganisation, glaube ich. Dachorganisation und Staatsakt. Und das ist dann schon ganz interessant.
Was mich an Klemperer so beeindruckt hat, ist, dass das war seine Überlebensstrategie. Der Mann hat das Dritte Reich nur überleben können, weil er es analysiert und zerlegt hat. Und weil er darauf geachtet hat, was sie sagen. Und wenn man dieses Buch heute liest, also für mich war das ein Erweckungserlebnis. Ich habe das gelesen, da war ich 15 oder so in der DDR zu den Hochzeiten der sozialistischen Parolen. Und ich las dieses Buch und es war tatsächlich, es öffnete mir die Augen, weil es erklärte mir ein ganzes System anhand der Sprache, anhand der Worte, die verwendet wurden. Und ich bewundere diesen Mann bis heute für seine Fähigkeit, eben durch nichts weiter als durch Zuhören, Erkenntnisse zu gewinnen, für die andere Menschen ein Leben lang brauchen durch Erleiden.
Ja, auf jeden Fall eines der lesenswertesten Bücher in dem ganzen Themenkomplex, wenn wir auch noch als Buchtrip verlinken.
Ich hab's zumindest auch aus der DDR. Das war damals bei Regler mit Leipzig erschienen und mir hat das irgendwer geschenkt, als ich mal auf Besuch war.
Ja, es war auch ein, ich fand's immer wieder erstaunlich, dass sie es tatsächlich immer noch verlegt haben.
Ich fand's unglaublich, dass sie es verlegt haben. Ich konnte es wirklich kaum glauben.
Es war antifaschistisch, deshalb will ich, dass es immer wieder kommt.
Es war so entlarvend, weil auch gerade in der DDR viele dieser Worte, die Klempera zerlegt hat oder die weiterbenutzt wurden, oder auch die Entstehungsgeschichte in der DDR ähnlich war, wie auch im Dritten Reich und so. Irre.
Naja, mit dem Antifaschismus in der DDR war er auch sehr differenziert. Also da war ja nicht so, dass alle Antifaschisten gut waren. Es ist ja so, dass wir haben ja diese Trennung jetzt zwischen dem bürgerlichen Antifaschismus, der im Westen hochgehalten wird, und dem kommunistischen Antifaschismus, der im Osten hochgehalten wurde. Und der Klempera war ja eigentlich nicht so richtig auf der kommunistischen Seite verortet. Insofern war es schon erstaunlich, dass sie es halt immer noch verlegt haben.
Er wurde aber als Opfer ja dann wieder eingesetzt als Professor und wurde auch dort hochgehalten als antifaschistische Ikone, obwohl er eigentlich ein bürgerlicher war. Und das interessante ist jetzt, das kann man dann auch noch als Leseempfehlung geben, er hat ja weiter Tagebuch geführt und er hat sich dann auch mit der DDR auseinandergesetzt. Und das ist dann auch nochmal... Ich meine, diese Tagebücher sind anstrengend zu lesen, weil er wirklich alles Mögliche aufgeschrieben hat, so aus seinem Alltagsleben und so. Das ist richtig anstrengend. Und gerade halt diese letzten Sachen, weil die auch unheimlich ausführlich sind, da musste er es ja nicht mehr ins Geheimen machen. Dann hat er also unheimlich viel aufgeschrieben. Und das ist natürlich dann schon schwerer Stoff zum Lesen. Aber da sieht man eben auch, dass er eigentlich nicht der Antifaschist war, den die DDR gerne gehabt hätte. Dann sieht er natürlich da auch wieder die Probleme und auch Probleme in der Sprache.
Das ist auch so eine Sache eigentlich. Der Begriff bürgerlich ist eigentlich auch verbrannt, oder? Also heute ist es eher so ein Schimpfwort. Gut, das mag jetzt hier vielleicht auch ein bisschen mit Berlin zusammenhängen.
Also eigentlich nicht mehr.
Aber bürgerlich liegt es schon wieder am Wandeln?
Ist schon wieder am Wandeln. Also es ist halt so, dass der, also diese, wenn jetzt so die, die Brunsslauer Berg-Hipster meint, die jetzt irgendwie Kinder bekommen haben und in die Bürgerwohnungen eingezogen sind, die sind halt eben nicht bürgerlich aus der Sicht der Bürger.
Der Bürger kommt wieder in Mode.
Ja, genau. Der Bürger, der Bürger an sich, also als jemand, der sich um sein Gemeinwesen schert, fängt wieder gerade an positiver besetzt zu werden. Also dieser Begriff des Wutbürgers.
Der Wutbürger, genau.
Der war sehr schön.
Der war sehr schön, weil es war ja eben genau der, der Versuch eben der Diffamierung genau dieses, dieses Phänomens, dass die Leute sich plötzlich wieder kümmern.
Um ihre Bürgerrechte.
Um ihre Bürgerrechte, ja.
Ich hab halt mal so eine, so eine Zensursular-Rede gesehen, wo sie wirklich in einem Fort vom bürgerlichen Engagement war, glaube ich, geredet hat. Also, da haben wir ja...
Naja, sie reden mittlerweile, reden sie nicht mehr von bürgerlichen, sondern von zivilgesellschaftlichem Engagement. Ach du Scheiße.
Also die Idee war jedenfalls, da ging es darum, dass die Leute noch alle freiwillig und kostenlos arbeiten sollen für die, fürs Gemeinwohl und ehrenamtlich.
Und sich nicht darum kümmern sollen, was ihre Politiker für einen Scheiß machen.
Nein, die sollen sich aus der Politik raushalten und sollen sich beschäftigen, indem sie ehrenamtlich tätig sind.
Die sollen das Geld für die Bürgermeisterstellen sparen.
Ehrenamt ist natürlich auch so ein geiles Wort, ne? Amt, Ehrenhalfer. Ja, ihr seht schon, wenn man mal anfängt, mit der Sprache auseinanderzufüßeln.
Ist das wie so Wikipedia, kann man noch, wenn man einmal anfängt zu knicken.
Ihr hattet noch eine zweite Buchempfehlung von?
Ambrose Beers.
Ambrose Beers, das ist auch normal. Dann sagst du was zu Ambrose Beers und ich sag dann was zu Edward Burnies.
Ambrose Beers war in der Zeit des amerikanischen Bürgerkriegs und danach ein, ich glaube, ziemlich verbitterter Journalist und Autor, der müsste dir gefallen, weil er strotzt vor Zynismus. Er hat in seinem Devil's Dictionary, dem Teufels Wörterbuch nichts weiter getan, als alltägliche Begriffe zynisch umzudeuten und so ihre tatsächlich verwendete Bedeutung hervorzukehren. Großartig.
Das ist eine große Quelle von Zitaten.
Allerdings ist das jetzt nicht so sprachanalytisch.
Es ist gesellschaftskritisch. Er benutzt Sprache als Instrument der Gesellschaftskritik.
Ja, und den anderen, den man unbedingt empfehlen muss, ist Edward Burnishs. Das Buch heißt Propaganda und man denkt, es geht um Staatspropaganda, was es jetzt sich dann doch tut. Aber es geht da um Public Relations. Es gibt zahlreiche Beispiele in dem Buch, das ist wirklich auch kurzweilig zu lesen, weil er zeigt, wie man Produkte besser auf den Markt bringt und unterstützt, dadurch, dass man die richtigen Formulierungen findet. Also es geht so ein bisschen eben tatsächlich um Werbesprache, aber eben auch die Aufforderung, dass das auch in der Politik eine Bedeutung haben muss. Und das ist offensichtlich ein Buch, was dann viele gelesen haben, obwohl das aus den 20er Jahren ist.
Haben wir das verlinkt? Wir haben das gar nicht verlinkt im Blog.
Das haben wir gar nicht verlinkt.
Das müssen wir noch verlinken im Blog.
Und das ist natürlich dann nicht ganz folgenlos geblieben. Also ich glaube, dass viele dieser Ideen, dass man Sprache auch einsetzen soll, auch um die Politik in Anführungszeichen zu verkaufen, tatsächlich auf etwas Burnies zurückgehen.
Und in der Werbung ist es ja auch so, dass der, also da gibt es zwei Aspekte. Zum einen gibt es ja dieses Verkaufen. Und dann, also wenn man versucht, den Leuten irgendwas aufzudrücken und ihnen das Geld aus der Tasche zu ziehen. Und dann gibt es ja dieses Post-Sales. Also das, wenn sie dein Geld schon haben und du nur noch ein Beförderungsfall bist.
Jaja, genau.
Also ein Beförderungsfall ist ja auch so ein schönes Wort.
Oder wenn mal was schief gelaufen ist, dass man dann einen Cover abmacht.
Wie war das, Bahnsprech?
Jaja, Bahnsprech. Jaja, Bahnsprech ist wirklich, also ich erlebe das ja, weil ich so häufig mit der Bahn fahre. Das ist wirklich unglaublich.
Die führen wir glaube ich bald ein. Wir haben schon ein, zwei Begriffe, die dazu passen und es wird eine eigene Kategorie.
Also die, jetzt beim letzten Bahnfahrt stellte ich fest, dass die DB-Launch, auch so ein schönes Wort, am Hauptbahnhof mittlerweile nicht mehr da ist, wo man sie erwartet, weil sie gerade umgebaut wird. Und das ist jetzt halt die temporäre DB-Launch. Und das heißt dann, also früher hat man gesagt, so was wie behelfs-Mitropa oder so.
Mitropa ist auch verbrannt.
Die haben, glaube ich, die Firma auch umbenannt. Ich glaube, die heißt ja hier Mitropa.
Vielleicht heißt die GmbH dahinter doch irgendwo, der holt die doch irgendwo Mitropa aus richtigen Gründen. Aber da ist ja, also die haben ja genau den Versuch, mehr wie eine Fluggesellschaft auszusehen, der so ein bisschen hinter diesem ganzen deutschen Bahn ummodeln steht. Und der hat sich ja eben auch genau in diesen Begrifflichkeiten niedergeschlagen. So das ist halt dann irgendwie der Service-Assistent, der dir denn deinen Kaffee bringt. Und also genau diese, diese Anglifizierung, so das ist halt nicht mehr die, keine Ahnung, Betreuerin oder was auch immer. Und der Schaffner heißt auch nicht mehr Schaffner, sondern wie heißt der jetzt? Fahr- Zugbetreuer heißt der, glaube ich, ne?
Ja, Zugbetreuer, ja, Zugbetreuer.
Zugbetreuer heißt der.
Bahnchef. Nee, ne, Zugchef.
Der Zugchef ist ein vieles anderes, aber es gibt noch den...
Der Zugchef ist der Chef von den Schaffnern.
Genau, und da gibt es noch die Zugbetreuer, das sind halt die...
Das Service Center ist das Klo.
Nee, nee, das ist woanders, ja.
Auf den Bahnhöfen.
Jaja, da ist es das Service Center, ja.
Aber da habe ich immer so den Eindruck, dass er die Leute eher anödet. Also, dass halt da die Schwelle zu, ja...
Zu übertreiben einfach. Also nicht umsonst gab es ja bei der Bahn eine Initiative der CSU, glaube ich, oder der CDU, die die Bahn möge doch bitte wieder Deutsch einführen als Amtssprache und nicht Englisch.
War das nicht bei der Telekom?
Oder Telekom, eins dieser ehemaligen Staatsunternehmen, da wurde dringend gebeten...
Ja, aber das Thank you for traveling wurde auch abgeschafft.
Also das haben sie nur auf der internationalen Strecke. Da muss man aber schon gesuchte Strecken fahren. Aber gerade bei Telekommunikationsunternehmen ist es ja auch extrem. Also das ist halt einfach egal wie, irgendwie müssen die Angizismen verwendet werden. Und die Leute verstehen es einfach auch nicht mehr. Also gerade...
Du sollst nicht verstehen, um Gottes Willen. Das ist doch der Sinn der Übung. Du sollst deinen Telekom Vertrag nicht verstehen.
Ja, vor allen Dingen die Tarife. Das ist ja immer die Tarife. Complete, Partner, Plus. Was soll das heißen? Ich meine, complete ist halt auch complete. Was ist da M und S und L und Plus und Partner?
Das Schöne an dem ganzen Thema ist, wir können alle sprechen und deswegen vergessen wir so schnell, was für ein machtvolles Instrument Sprache ist und was man als anstellen kann. Das ist für mich auch so eine Motivation dieses Blogs einfach so was zu zeigen. Irgendwie daran zu erinnern, was man mit Sprache alles tun kann und wie kreativ man damit sein kann.
Ja, wie wehren wir uns denn?
Das macht ihr ja schon die ganze Zeit.
Ich meine, abgesehen davon, dass wir einen Blog machen und hier einen Podcast dazu, aber wie können wir uns denn wehren? Ist das überhaupt zielführend, wenn wir da unsere eigenen Begriffe?
Es geht nicht um wehren, es geht um Bewusstseinschaffen.
Bewusstseinschaffen denke ich auch. Und dass man die Sachen auch nicht...
Damit mache ich es auch machtloser, wenn ich die Leute aufkläre.
Genau. Es gibt zwei Arten, sich zu wehren. Einmal, dass man eben selber auch die richtigen Begriffe prägt und Werte darauf legt, dass die dann auch verwendet werden.
Das ist auch legitim und das ist nicht...
Das ist sicherlich legitim.
Ein Mittel des Klösen.
Nee, also die Sprache... Ich meine, es gibt nicht das wahre Wort für die wahre Bedeutung. Das ist halt nicht... Das ist nie so. Naja, und der andere Punkt ist aber auch, dass man diese Sache, dass man tatsächlich bewusst mit der Sprache umgeht und auch genauer hinschaut. Also ich denke, gerade wenn ich jetzt wieder an diesen Netzbericht der CSU denke, wenn man das einfach nur so überfliegt, dann klingt das schön, hat man auch schnell gelesen. Das lässt sich wirklich gut lesen.
Netzbericht ist auch nicht schlecht. Sie berichten über das Netz.
Aber wenn man halt...
Über den Internet-Notstand.
Wenn man ein bisschen genauer hinschaut, dann merkt man eben, dass es alles irgendwie Neusprech. Aber da muss man halt genauer hinschauen. Und deshalb eben auch so der Appell, guckt da genauer hin. Und naja, wenn man halt so ein Wort bei neusprech.org oder sonst wo schon als verdächtig gefunden hat, dann merkt man auch plötzlich, dass es da auch verdächtig verwendet wird.
Habt ihr eigentlich eine Denunzierungs-Hotline?
Ja, na klar. Twitter und Facebook.
Kann man euch verdächtige Wörter melden.
Das passiert dauernd. Tatsächlich bin ich begeistert. Ich bin wirklich begeistert. Fast täglich kommen Vorschläge und so. Wir können gar nicht so viel schreiben.
Das finde ich auch sehr schön. Also das hat dann wirklich den Nerv getroffen, weil die Leute reagieren und eben was zuschicken. Und ich kriege auch ab und an E-Mails, habe ich auch schon gesagt nach meinen Vorträgen. Ich habe einmal von einem Ministerialdirigenten aus einem ostdeutschen Bundesland Details darüber bekommen, dass eben dort tatsächlich auch das genaue Abklopfen von Sprache in Vorbereitung auf die Auftritte des Ministers zur Dienstaufgabe gehört.
Achso.
Ja. Ja, naja, so viel stand da nicht drin. Der hat halt nur gesagt, dass...
Machen wir.
Dass das gemacht wird und dass es auch sehr nötig sei, da nach der Wende eben auch sprachlich herausgeforderte Politiker nach Osten entsorgt worden sind.
Oh, das erklärt aber einiges.
Ja, also da gibt's offensichtlich spezielles...
Sagst du immer, das ist ein Dialekt?
Spezielles Fosüge. Ja, und dann hab ich halt noch so ein, zwei Mails bekommen, wo man dann drauf hingewiesen hat, wie es so abgeht. Auch eben der Hinweis auf Bertelsmann und so. Das kann da alles.
Also das sollte man vielleicht nochmal wiederholen. Genau, diese Initiative Neue Soziale Merkwirtschaft, das zeigt ja irgendwie auch aus dem Kontext der Bertelsmann Stiftung. Und wann immer diese Leute unterwegs sind, da muss man ganz genau hingucken. Die sind doch große Meister in sich neue Begrifflichkeiten ausdenken, die dann meistens total harmlos und fluffig und flauschig klingen und aber doch irgendwie einen eisenharten Umverteilungskern haben. Da geht es eigentlich doch immer ganz gut zur Sache.
Übrigens Mail, Wirtschaftsregierung, was wir heute geblockt haben, das kam gestern per Mail.
Wirtschaftsregierung, ja.
Was ist denn eine Wirtschaftsregierung?
Keine Ahnung. Wir wissen es nicht.
Die Kanzlerin hat doch so ein bisschen berichtet, was sie sich darunter vorstellt. Also, Rente ab 67 und keine automatische Lohnerhöhung bei Inflation und so.
Das hat doch alles nichts mit Regierung zu tun. Das betrifft doch die Bürger.
Ja, das soll aber in ganz Europa, also die Sozialsysteme sollen nach voneinander abgestimmt werden. Harmonisieren. Harmonisierung ist auch so ein Bauch, wenn man da reinträgt. Harmonisierung der Sozialsysteme. Deshalb geht es ja gar nicht um Wirtschaft da, sondern müsste dann Sozialabbau-Regierung heißen oder so. Aber das interessante dabei ist auch, dass diese Regierung sozusagen als Schatten-Regierung fungieren soll. Also ohne parlamentarische Kontrolle. Also ohne parlamentarische Kontrolle. Schatten passt vielleicht nicht, aber jedenfalls. Ja, also eine Gruppe, die die halt neben der Regierung oder über die eigentliche Regierung hinweg regiert und über das Parlament und so, ich weiß nicht. Du würdest sie wahrscheinlich Hunder nennen.
Natürlich. Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an die Wirtschaftsweisen. Da wird ja auch nie erklärt, wer ist das eigentlich, wieso sind die Weise.
Ja, aber bei Regierungen ist ja schon sozusagen der Anspruch formuliert.
Das klingt so ein bisschen wie EU, wo man seine, die sind schuld. Das sind zwar auch wir, aber wir sind nicht.
Nee, das ist der Anspruch, wir regieren dich. Das ist wer, da was.
Nee, ihr geht's ja gerade darum, das von sich selbst wegzuzeigen, oder? Das ist doch immer das Problem bei den Politikern, dass sie Dinge tun wollen, die das Volk nicht mag und dass sie ein Konstrukt brauchen, damit sie das zwar machen können, aber nicht schuld sind.
Ja, aber die Ausführungen von Merkel weisen eher darauf hin, dass am deutschen Wesen die Welt genesen soll. Also wir haben hier erfolgreich Sozialabbau getrieben, also nicht wir, also die jesige Regierung hat das getan und das soll jetzt gefälligst in ganz Europa passieren. Super, weil die anderen ja irgendwie da so früh in Rente gehen und sich die Löhne erhöhen und so und das geht ja mal gar nicht. Also die erfolgreiche Lohnsenkungspolitik Deutschlands soll jetzt auch woanders eingeführt werden.
Ganz prima.
Tja, wenn da mal nicht eine Schutzlücke entsteht, nicht wahr? Eine Schutzlücke, ja.
Ein Reformstau.
Ja, Schutzlücke fand ich irgendwie, die kann man so in der Argumentation zur Vorratsdeutensprecherung.
Gibt ja auch noch die Fähigkeitslücke, ne?
Ja, die Fähigkeitslücke, ja, die gibt es auch. Was sind denn so eure, so Richtung Abschluss, eure Lieblingsneusprechworte des letzten Jahres?
Na, des letzten Jahres ist schwierig. Das letzte Jahr ist wahrscheinlich wirklich alternativlos. Wenn man das auf längere Sicht sieht, ist mein Lieblingswort nach wie vor der potenzielle Gefährder, weil das so weit weg ist. Also ich meine, ein Gefährder ist schon jemand, der noch nichts gemacht hat. Also der ist wirklich, also Gefährder ist unschuldig. Also ein potenzieller Störer wäre es vielleicht ein Gefährder. Und jetzt wird der aber noch mal potenziert. Also der potenzielle, potenzielle Störer. Und ich finde, das ist so weit, also so entschärft. Aber da sieht man eben auch so schön den Wandel, weil Gefährder alleine noch nicht reicht. Potenzielle sein. Und das ist halt wirklich die komplette Verkehrung der Welt, weil letztlich wir alle potenzielle Gefährder sind. Denn wir gefährden ja nicht, sondern nur potenziell.
Potenziell gefährlich. Und dein Lieblingswort?
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keins. Ich bin bei jedem Wort, über das ich mir dann länger Gedanken mache, weil das ist ja der Witze, ich setze mich dann hin und überlege, ja Gott, was können die denn gemeint haben? Das ist ja mal erstmal das Erste, ne?
Die schwierige Frage manchmal.
Das ist wirklich schwer. Das ist manchmal, um Gottes Willen, was war jetzt die Absicht?
Aber Kai, dein Bestes, also was mir von deinem am besten gefallen hat, ist Just in Time. Out of Store. Also besser kann man es nicht übersetzen.
Just in Time ist in der Tat wirklich ein, ja.
Wobei es schon so in Beratersprech reingeht, ne? Das ist ja wirklich der Versuch, einfach durch irgendeinen englischen Begriff irgendwas ganz anderes zu sagen. Ne, es ist wirklich so, dass mich begeistert diese Kreativität. Da müssen Leute sitzen, die sich einen Kopf machen, wie kann man das jetzt schön, sachlich, harmlos, unverfänglich, genau ausformulieren? Und dann kommen Worte raus, auf die ich nie kommen würde. Das ist unglaublich.
Auch da muss ich sagen, Just in Time ist nicht einfach Berater sprech. Das qualifiziert inzwischen die ganze Gesellschaft, die ganze Wirtschaft. Hier alles irgendwie nur grad so eben und dann bricht es auseinander.
Bedarfsorientiert.
Ja.
Das Schöne ist...
Oh, ihr seid furchtbar, ich lade mir die wieder ein.
Das Schöne ist, dass bedarfsorientiert ist sozialistisch. Das ist ein Wort aus der sozialistischen Sprache. Wir orientieren den Wirtschaftsplan am Bedarf.
Ja, genau.
Was ist denn die bessere Strategie? Gegenwörter zu erfinden oder lieber darauf gucken, dass die bestehenden Wörter erkannt werden, entlauft werden und zu ihrer schlechten Bedeutung zurückkehren.
Mit Gegenwörtern machst du es ja nur noch schlimmer.
Entschuldigung, aber Kreativität ist immer die beste Vorwärtsverteidigung sozusagen.
Kann man das dann herbeiführen, dass wir jetzt so etwas wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wenn wir so etwas gezielt entkernen wollen und das Wort verbrennen wollen, kann man das herbeiführen? Gibt es da irgendwie Strategien für oder?
Ich glaube schon.
Ja, man muss...
Exzessive Verwendung.
Also selber eine Stiftung aufbauen, neue unsoziale Marktwirkung.
Guckt euch doch an, allein die Tatsache, dass wir über dieses Wort geblockt haben, ihr diese Seite aufgesetzt habt mit einem Podcast, der Alternativlos heißt, hat, da bin ich sicher, dazu geführt, dass es zum Unwort anhand wurde und damit tot ist, und zwar für alle Zeiten. Also in den nächsten 10, 20 Jahren wird das keiner mehr vorholt.
Wobei es noch nicht ganz angekommen bei den Politikern, oder?
Jetzt wo es Unwort des Jahres ist, das haben die schon mal in irgendeiner Rubrik in der FRZ gelesen und denken sich, ups, das darf man nicht.
Das ist wieder was Neues.
Ich meine auch die Reform.
Exzessive Verwendung.
Also einfach durch Verwendung verbrennen.
Das können wir ja mal auf die Agenda setzen.
Das sind vielleicht jedes Wort nur so eine minimale Belichtungszeit sozusagen. Also kann es nur eine gewisse Menge an Aufmerksamkeit nicht vertragen, bevor es dann einfach abhört. Wie alles im Leben.
Bis es albern wird.
Ja, aber bei Sprache ist das wirklich so. Sprache wird gebraucht und dann verändert sich durch den Gebrauch die Semante, beziehungsweise das Verblast. Also das besonders neue Verblast. Das ist dann eben, wie wir gesehen haben, bei den neuartigen Empfangsgeräten, das ist auch schon nicht mehr.
Da sind dann nur sehr wenige übrig, die halt so wie Arbeitgeber, Arbeitnehmer dann wirklich in den Sprachbuch und im Sprachgebuch übergehen.
Ja, das können wir uns ja auch mal zum Ziel setzen, dass immer mehr zu belaufen.
Ja, genau, man muss mal was gegen Arbeitnehmer und Arbeitgeber machen. Also gegen die Wörter.
Revolution!
Wir haben uns ja schon gegenseitig befruchtet. So bei den Vorbereitungen haben wir bei den Listen geführt. So alles wollten wir auch schon immer mal machen. Und auch das Neusprechblock hat ein paar Inspirationen mitgenommen. Ja, insofern schon jetzt eine erfolgreiche Sendung. Ja, vielen Dank, dass ihr gekommen seid.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Das war doch eine sehr schöne Sendung. Ja, dann vielleicht nächstes Jahr mal wieder mit den Updates.
Mal unbedingt.
Nächstes Jahr gibt es erst mal ein Buch, da haben wir genug zu tun.
Oh, ich habe ein Buch vor.
Oh, sehr cool. Erzähl doch mal.
Sehr schön.
Ja, ein Lexikon, damit man das auch auf dem Kaffeetisch legen kann, damit es dann auch die Oma zur Hand nimmt und lacht und so.
Damit sie Ausdrucker auch lesen können.
Weil dieses Internet, das ist doch, das erreicht auch längst nicht alle.
Ja, guter Plan, finde ich gut. Neusprechlexikon fehlt auf jeden Fall.
Werden wir pluggen.
Können wir machen.
Können wir einscannen.
Genau, wir scannen das ein und schicken es als Word-Attachment.
Nun gut, dann vielen Dank fürs Kommen nochmal.
Ja, und wir sehen uns in ungefähr zwei Wochen wieder beim nächsten Podcast.
Genau, beim nächsten Alternativlos. Auf Wiederhören.